first we're joined by fox news
contributor former congressman trey
Gowdy congressman let's get your
reaction now that we know tonight that
the Attorney General has in fact
assigned this US Attorney in Connecticut
to review the origins of the Russian
inquiry that and what are the questions
would you like answered well this is the
fourth person that's been charged with
investigating the origins of the Russia
probe so I'm more interested and and how
quickly they do it and how effectively
they do it more than the number so if
this is the right person to do it more
power tool there's an easy roadmap to
follow
Sean we know the origins of the Russia
probe what Russia did to us I want to
know the origins of when the bureau
began to intermingle the Trump campaign
with the Russia probe you just quoted
Lindsey Graham as saying they want to
stop Trump oh all Lizzie was doing was
quoting Peters truck that's what Peter
struck said in a text no we'll stop it
so what are the origins then I want to
know how did the FBI assess Christopher
Steele they have their own internal
documents part of what Lindsey wants to
make public or the internal FBI
documents where they did their own
assessment and I think you'll be
surprised at whether or not they viewed
Steele as being was this thing this is
all in the gang of eight information I'm
told my sources I saw it before I left I
know Johnny Radcliffe say that I I know
exactly what Johnny and Lindsay are
talking about they're talking about
internal FBI documents where they did
their own assessment of whether or not
Chris steel was a reliable they're
talking about 302s where an FBI
informant said he'd do anything in the
world to make sure Donald Trump lost
that wasn't a D&C employee that was an
FBI informant before they got rid of him
for breaking FBI Goudy what Lindsay
you're you're a great prosecutor let me
ask you a series of quick questions you
convinced that FBI agents as well as the
Attorney General of the time Loretta
Lynch that they've rigged Hillary's
investigation I am convinced that they
handled that investigation in a way
unlike any investigation I have ever
seen handled
for and the fact that you still have to
ask that question Shawn after what
12-month investigation by the world's
premier law enforcement agency the
meeting on the tarmac the fact that
Comey had to threaten special counsel
you mentioned that Comey leaked memos
because he wanted a special counsel
appointed for Trump even were supposed
to do when he had questions about what
he do when he had questions about
Loretta Lynch did you see him leak
anything then nope
ATS is clear isn't it if you have
top-secret classified information on a
private server is that not a violation
of the Espionage Act a clear one if you
handle it negligently yes okay well we
know was handled negligently and would
it be for example that would there be in
tension if you delete 33,000 subpoenaed
emails acid-wash your hard drive with
bleach pit bust up your devices and with
hammers and pull out SIM cards sir you
never lost the case would that be a good
case for obstruction of justice of clear
and convincing case one beyond any
reasonable doubt
it is fantastic evidence on the issue of
intent which is what Comey said he
didn't have it is consciousness of
wrongdoing it is knowledge all of that
in addition to the multiple
misstatements demonstrable fault
statement was made was handling of it
are you convinced that there was a fraud
committed against the FISA Court with
holding that Hillary paid for that
dossier and that in fact the bulk of
evidence was unverifiable and that they
never verified whether anything steel
road is true and did they do it to spy
on the Trump campaign sir Shawn I can
tell you it is even worse than what you
described it is what you described in
addition to the withholding of its culpa
Tory information which is what has
Johnny Ratcliffe so exercised and they
made no effort to corroborate the
dossier until after it had been used in
the application and a renewal no effort
it's not that they failed they made no
effort to ask question so whoever is
investigating this tell them to look for
EM emails between Brennan and Comey in
December of 2016 are you convinced that
that phony Russian dossier bought by
Hillary Clinton created by steel that
they lied
- with the FISA Court are you convinced
they tried to undo a president duly
elected president in the United States
and take him down I'm just going based
on what Peter struck said he thought
he'd be the lead agent in charge of
investigating this said he thought Trump
would be destabilizing had an insurance
policy and then promised his lover that
we will stop it so you answer it well
said you never lost the case did you
thank you sir